Понад два з половиною мільйони громадян України виїхали за кордон від початку війни, повідомляє ООН.
Кореспонденти DW побували в різних країнах, аби переконатися на власні очі,
як відбувається прийом українських біженців.
Варшава та Краків більше не можуть приймати біженців із України, повідомляють прикордонники.
Загалом за останні три тижні Польща прийняла понад мільйон українців -
це чи не більше, ніж всі інші європейські країни разом.
У центрі Варшави у костелі Святого Олександра продовжує працювати пункт допомоги біженцям з України.
Тут окрім поляків, вимушеним переселенцям активно допомагають також білоруси.
Нині ми, білоруси, солідарні з українцями.
Ми прагнемо підтримати їх. Адже ми теж змушені були покинути свою країну,
борючись із прокремлівським режимом Лукашенка.
Щоденно волонтери приймають та сортують гуманітарну допомогу -
одяг, ліки, намети, засоби гігієни, білизну, посуд.
Пожертв так багато, що волонтерам довелося відкрити другий склад.
Але й попит на допомогу великий. Потік тих, хто звертається сюди, - нескінченний, каже волонтер.
Волонтери працюють і тут, і на другому складі.
На цьому складі ведеться робота з людьми.
Приїжджають українці, ми підбираємо для них найнеобхідніше на перші дні.
Перебування українських біженців у в Польщі узаконили на 18 місяців.
Українські учні та студенти зможуть продовжити навчання у польських школах та університетах.
Біженці з України також матимуть право на фінансову допомогу та працевлаштування.
Німецьке суспільство також активно долучається до підтримки українців.
Волонтери допомагають їм із житлом, а після реєстрації у місцевих органах влади,
українці зможуть отримувати також фінансову допомогу від держави.
Німець Майк Фридрих з Франкфурта-на-Одері долучився до допомоги українцям,
і тепер його офіс більше схожий на склад.
Так, тут їжа та предмети гігієни, одяг окремо…
Фрідріх та його подруга Боба Пройс Бойчич почали збирати гуманітарну допомогу
одразу після вторгнення російських військ в Україну.
Вони планують передати гуманітарну допомогу через Польщу до українського кордону.
Я родом із Югославії. У дитинстві я пережила війну. Моя сім'я втратила все, у нас не було нічого.
Доброго дня. У мене є трохи продуктів, хочу віддати їх.
Родичі Тетяни Альбрехт живуть у Києві, але зв'язку з ними немає.
Тетяна відчуває відповідальність за них.
У людей є потреби. А у мене є час на даний момент, тож я збираю все і віддаю, що необхідно людям.
Охочих допомогти дуже багато.
Приходить багато таких, які досі не мали жодних зав'язків з Україною.
Ця справа кожного, це відбувається у нас на порозі.
Ніхто не знає, як далеко може зайти війна.
Ось чому так важливо проявляти солідарність.
У той час як Польща і Німеччина приймають всіх українців, в іншій частині світу, Ізраїлі,
до українських біженців ставляться більш вибірково.
Я зараз вся на емоціях. То плачу, то сміюся, не перестаючи.
Я навіть не знаю, що сказати... Мені просто хочеться спати і відчувати себе в безпеці.
І я знаю, що тут безпечно. Адже зі мною моя сім'я і люди…
Я просто не знаю, як мені висловити свою подяку.
Анна разом із мамою і сестрою виїхали з Києва спершу до Польщі, потім до Ізраїлю.
Жінки мають тут родичів. Анна часто відвідувала країну, але не думала, що повернеться сюди за таких обставин.
На даний момент міграційна служба надала родині прихисток у Тель-Авіві.
Право на імміграцію до Ізраїлю відповідно до законодавства мають лише українці єврейського походження.
На тлі війни влада Ізраїлю оголосила про надання тимчасового притулку 5 тисячам українських біженців,
які не мають єврейського коріння.
Однак ця квота вже вичерпана. До того ж, Ізраїль припинив дію безвізового режиму для України.
Тепер українцям, які хочуть в'їхати до країни, потрібно спочатку отримати спеціальний дозвіл МВС Ізраїлю.
Ще одна країна, яка зволікає з прийомом українських біженців - Великобританія.
У той час, коли ЄС вже оголосив, що дасть притулок усім українцям, які цього потребують,
Лондон дозволив прибуття біженців лише за умови, що вони мають тут родичів і отримають візу.
Тому перед посольством Сполученого Королівства у Польщі вишикувалися довгі черги з українців.
Як, приміром, Олександра Витяганець, яка живе у Великобританії,
але вирушила до польського кордону, щоб забрати свою матір.
Це був кошмар, але я думаю, що нам пощастило, тому що ми в безпеці, і мама вижила.
Адже коли вона приїжджала з Києва, місто обстрілювали росіяни.
Було дуже страшно, чи вдасться нам зустрітися…
Це було нелегко, але ми розуміємо обставини, це час війни…
Ми просто дуже щасливі, що ми зараз тут, у безпечному місці.
Однак після критики британського уряду в надмірній бюрократії, умови для українців спростили.
Тепер втікачі від війни можуть прибувати до Сполученого Королівства без візи і без наявності родичів, які там живуть.
Єдина умова - знайти людину чи організацію в Британії, які зголосяться надати переселенцям прихисток.
Сусідня з Україною Молдова також приймає переселенців.
Сюди насамперед тікають українці з півдня країни - Херсонщини, Миколаївщини, Одещини.
І хоча більшість біженців сприймають Молдову лише як зупинку на шляху до інших країн ЄС,
понад 100 тисяч українців наразі перебувають у Молдові.
Уряд країни скаржиться на брак коштів для утримання такої кількості біженців.
Минулого тижня Кишинів заявив, що потік біженців буде перенаправлений з молдовського кордону на румунський,
а всі витрати на транспортування візьме на себе Бухарест.
Міністр закордонних справ Молдови Ніку Попеску заявив, що утримання біженців щодня обходиться країні приблизно у 3 млн доларів.
Третина покривається з бюджету та благодійних фондів,
решту коштів виділяють закордонні партнери.
Але й без того фінансове навантаження на одну з найбідніших країн Європи - величезне.